The Man Who Fought in WWII With a Sword and
Bow
Running into battle armed with a broadsword,
bow, and quiver of arrows was perfectly acceptable
if you were fighting in the Hundred Years’
War or fending off some orcs on Middle Earth.
But when it comes to World War II, such medieval
weaponry looks like child’s play next to
the technology of the time.
A sword isn’t the most likely of defences
against rifles and tanks.
However, for John Malcolm Thorpe Fleming Churchill,
nicknamed “Mad Jack,” there was nothing
he’d rather arm himself with than a trusty
sword and bow.
Born into an old Oxfordshire family, he graduated
from the Royal Military Academy at Sandhurst
in 1926.
Before his World War II fame, Mad Jack worked
as an editor of a Nairobi newspaper, a model,
and a movie extra, appearing in The Thief
of Bagdad due to his expertise with a bow.
That same talent with archery took him to
Oslo, Norway where he shot for Britain during
the world championships in 1939.
By this time, of course, Europe was fast approaching
World War II.
Mad Jack had left the army after ten years
of service, but happily returned to it because
of the “country having gotten into a jam
in my absence.”
By May 1940, Mad Jack was the second in command
of an infantry company.
He always marched into battle with a bow and
arrows and his trusty basket-hilted claymore
by his side.
Despite these weapons being wildly outdated,
Churchill defended them, saying, “In my
opinion…any officer who goes into action
without his sword is improperly dressed.”
His medieval weaponry wasn’t just for decoration,
either.
During the 1940 Battle of Dunkirk—in which
300,000 troops became stranded on beaches
and had to be evacuated—Churchill struck
down a German soldier with a well-placed arrow.
He was later seen chugging along on a motorcycle
with his bow strapped to the side.
A German officer’s cap was hanging on the
headlight.
In 1941, Mad Jack volunteered for Operation
Archery, an attack on a German garrison in
Norway, in which he led two companies during
the battle; no word on whether or not he was
able to use his bow in the aptly named operation.
In the battle, he and his companies were in
charge of taking out the German batteries
on Maaloy Island.
On the vessel bearing him to shore, Churchill
stood at the front playing his bagpipes to
the tune of “The March of the Cameron Men.”
When they landed, he charged ahead of the
rest of his men with his sword in hand.
His sword also served him well later, in 1943.
At the time, Mad Jack was a commanding officer
in Salerno when his troops were forced into
line fighting—something for which they hadn’t
been trained.
Churchill went ahead of his soldiers wielding
his sword.
He leapt out at German sentries from the darkness,
blade held high, and the Germans were so frightened
by the “demon” that they surrendered.
Churchill took 42 prisoners that night with
the help of just one other companion and his
trusty sword.
This was inline with his philosophy on fighting
the Germans, which he described after capturing
the 42:
I maintain that, as long as you tell a German
loudly and clearly what to do, if you are
senior to him he will cry ‘jawohl’ (yes
sir) and get on with it enthusiastically and
efficiently whatever the situation.
Next, Churchill was sent off to Yugoslavia
where he led a series of raids against the
Germans from the island of Vis.
In May 1944, a bigger operation was planned
involving three attacks on separate hilltop
positions.
Mad Jack led one group up one hill, but only
six of them managed to reach the target.
Jack found himself in open view of the enemy
with only a few able-bodied men to defend
him, so he did what any sensible soldier would
have done… he played his bagpipes—“Will
Ye No Come Back Again” this time—until
he was knocked unconscious by German grenades
and captured.
Churchill was placed in Sachsenhausen concentration
camp after being interrogated.
The Germans had believed that he was some
sort of relative of Winston Churchill, which
wasn’t the case, but he was still considered
a “prominent” prisoner due to his rank.
As you might expect, Mad Jack wasn’t one
to be kept in a prison camp.
He made a run for it that September by sneaking
through an old drain under the barbed wire.
He and a comrade were recaptured not long
after and moved to a camp in Austria.
In April 1945, the Austrian camp’s lighting
system failed.
Churchill took advantage of the opportunity
and melted into the darkness, walking away
from his work detail.
He simply kept walking, and eight days and
150 miles later, he ran into the armoured
vehicles of the United States Army in Italy.
He managed to convince them that he was a
British colonel despite his scruffy appearance,
and he was returned to safety.
Safety wasn’t exactly something Mad Jack
was after, though.
He was disappointed to learn that the war
was winding down and that he had missed a
year of it.
Rather than return home, he got himself assigned
to Burma where the war against Japan was still
in full swing.
By the time he got over there, though, the
bombs had been dropped on Nagasaki and Hiroshima,
meaning that the war was basically over.
An unhappy Churchill vented, “If it wasn’t
for those damn Yanks, we could have kept the
war going for another 10 years!”
The end of the war didn’t mean the end of
Churchill’s adventures, though.
He decided to train as a parachutist, and
when he qualified, he was sent into Palestine
as the second-in-command of the 1st Battalion.
He later became a land-air warfare instructor
in Australia, where he developed a love of
surfing.
He ended up retiring from the army in 1959
and died in 1996 in Surrey.
Mad Jack was known for throwing his briefcase
out of the train window.
His reasoning?
He was throwing it into his backyard, which
happened to be right by where the train rode
past.
This way, he didn’t have to lug it home
from the train station.